et pour en parler nous retrouvons une
amitié casalino chef du service des
urgences de l'hôpital bichat à paris
bonjour henrique casalino merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france ce matin alors
première question quelle est la
situation actuelle dans les hôpitaux de
paris on parle de 4 345 soignants de
l'ap-hp est contaminée par le cos vie 19
oui il y a un nombre important de
soignants qui ont été contaminées dans
les premières enquêtes dont nous
disposons le détail la moitié des
soignants à peu près ont été contaminées
à l'extérieur de l'hôpital et l'autre
moitié ce sont probablement des
contaminations au sein de l'hôpital
nous ne pouvons pas dire aujourd'hui que
les soignants sont à un risque accru
d'acquérir la maladie toutes les règles
de protection sont garantis et ça c'est
extrêmement important que les soignants
sache que tout est fait pour garantir
leur sécurité
le personnel médical justement at il les
moyens nécessaires pour répondre à cette
crise sanitaire
nous sommes actuellement confrontés à un
afflux très important de patients tous
les jours vous voyez bien quelle est la
vitesse d'augmentation de la courbe
aujourd'hui nous avons une très nette
augmentation des patients qui sont
hospitalisées et une très nette
augmentation des patients surtout qui
sont admis en réanimation
tout ceci fait que la consommation de
moyens de protection augmente de façon
importante mais je suis convaincu
qu'aujourd'hui toutes nos réserves de
matériel sont garantis la lisibilité de
notre possibilité à nourrir
l'approvisionner est également garantie
et si on doit modifier nos modes de
fonctionnement
ceci sera fait de telle façon que la
sécurité des personnels qui sont les
plus directement exposés
son rap toujours 40 10 on sert le pic de
l'épidémie est attendue pour mi avril
comment
et services médicaux peuvent-ils se
préparer la situation risque-t-elle
d'être ingérable est ce qu'on va faire
une saturation des services de
réanimation
si on voit le modèle de ce qui est
arrivé en italie ou de ceux qui arrivent
en espagne également les services ont
été mis en très très grande difficulté
la france a quand même un potentiel de
lits de réanimation plus élevé que les
autres pays
je pense qu'il est difficile d'imaginer
que au rythme actuel les services ont la
capacité nationale soit mise en
difficulté nous avons aussi des réserves
stratégiques de ventilateur d'un
potentiel d'équipé avec des machines
d'autres secteurs de l'hôpital
pour le moment il n'y a aucune raison de
penser que notre système de santé est
mise en difficulté le système de santé
est capable de réagir et capable de
mettre en place des structures et des
organisations innovantes et pour le
moment et dans les semaines à venir
notre système sera capable de répondre
et d'être performant merci beaucoup
henrique casalino d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes chef
du service des urgences de l'hôpital
bichat à paris